[Music]
let's guess is a New York Times
bestselling author the co-host of extra
now she's a contestant on the fourteenth
season of ABC's Dancing with the Stars
let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all that clip that's you're
doing an amazing job on the show and
you're a great dancer but let's look at
that clip right there saying that's not
dancing you and the guy are just making
out he puts you on the floor he gets on
top of you and you make out what dance
is that it sure looks like that I mean
you didn't know
until we saw the video afterwards I said
derec oh my gosh she could have look at
this video it looks like we were full-on
making out because no sir I just grazed
you I go oh no watch the video huge
fight going on because yesterday derp in
the results show he's like I saw the
video and I go yeah and he goes you
puckered I got did it he goes watch the
video and he kept her winding it on his
phone and I'm like I was dying of
embarrassed but that's what you do when
someone comes in and like I don't know
the moment I wasn't thinking we were
dancing yes she became one with the
dance yes that was the whole goal now
you've said that the biggest challenge
and I don't understand why you're saying
is we say the biggest challenge for you
and dancing is to be sexy I find that
impossible to understand I know it
doesn't make sense but I can I can pose
sexy for photos right I've been doing
that since I was young I've been
modeling so I get that but you have to
be confident to be sexy and I'm not
confident in dancing so I was really
nervous about it my parents would be
like everyday - you gotta be sexy don't
forget to be sexy today and I'm like
stop telling me to be sexy and so yeah
when your parents are yelling at you and
an accent to be sexy it doesn't right
you might work be brought up yeah now
that's weird
okay happy 5th birthday sexy like what
they set you off to school with but I
get to be sexy and they know me they
know like I'm goofy and fun and silly
and not that I'm comfortable think of
yourself is like a tomboy you don't
think of yourself that way exactly but I
had to and it was a real struggle
because you know we're in it I'm like
tariffs don't worry game time I'll pull
it out he's like you will like I don't
know but he'd be like I'm gonna just
take my hand just go burn I'm like it's
so uncomfortable weird maybe that's cuz
you're not attracted enough to him you
know no I mean have you looked at I'm
he's pretty handsome no no he's not this
it makes the difference yeah I think
with me please forget yourself yeah
the dance would be over left where are
my clothes
what happened every time it's never miss
dance would have been too hot for the
sentence you're right unfortunately we
had you know now what is the key to like
for example that the Rumba is is is the
Rumba what's the key to making the Rumba
a sexy dance do you think well from what
Derek would say is like eating that's
why this movements have to be sharp he's
like it's like slow quick-quick slow
like like you know very like sexy you
know so a rhythmic if you want to call
it he's never done a sexy rumba he
always does sweet rumbas but everyone on
Twitter was like go sexy go sexy and I'm
like yeah let's go sexy cuz I need to
overcome this challenge if I don't get
any further in this competition I wanted
to accomplish that because I knew is the
toughest thing for me to do right and I
accomplished it I feel very good so what
and so it's about it's about slow and
then quick quick quick and then slow
quick and what parts of your body are
you focusing on in that like what it's
like your hips it's like slow so like
when I was doing this turn I had to like
turn my hips slow and then right
I think it's bought I can give you
private lessons yes you may
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]